il faut cesser de considérer les
personnes en insertion comme des charges
pour la société ou alors de la main
d'oeuvre pas chère pour arrêter avec ça
c'est pas vrai c'est des gens qui ont
une vraie valeur à apporter et au
contraire qu'ils créeront l'alternative
on cherche tous actuellement
[Musique]
bonjour je suis prêt s'il ya petitjean
j'ai 33 ans ou lyonnaise et et
fondatrice des ateliers de lodève je me
suis enceinte projet parce que le vélo
m'a toujours accompagné mon nom ma vie
de mes premiers emplois on va dire au
dernier ça m'a apporté énormément et que
dans mon quotidien je ne voyais pas 100
et que ce sentiment que j'avais je
voulais le partage et le vélo d'un côté
et puis des renaissances humaine de
l'autre je me suis rendu compte que ça
fonctionnait hyper bien ensemble j'ai pu
former une centaine de personnes dans
une première structure sociale on a fait
des étincelles et à partir de là il y
avait une vraie volonté pouvoir aller de
l'avant est proposé on va dire la
station par le cycle à un maximum de
personnes
[Musique]
alors on a commencé on était une poignée
de fous furieux
on devait être trois vraiment mécano +
4/5 personnes à tout ce qui était un pad
ministre hâtif et à côté tous ou du
bénévolat pur aujourd'hui on est une
trentaine d'employés est normalement
l'objectif fin d'année c'est 60 des
employés
[Musique]
c'était un tout petit atelier qui
correspondait à peu près à la taille de
ce bureau
et bah maintenant tu vas chemin parcouru
jeu permet de voir dans de nouveaux
locaux
et voilà on est sur du 1000 1500 mètres
carrés oui
donc quand on parle d'insertion en fait
il faut penser à des publics qui sont
fragiles c'est des personnes qui sont
encore très en marge et de l'emploi et
de la santé et la société redire au
point sociale ou culturelle des
personnes qui ne travaillent pas depuis
très longtemps condé grosse rupture des
personnes qui ont des handicaps des
personnes qui ont des grosses
d'addiction des personnes qui ont des
barrières de la langue qu'on des
barrières juste pas les bons codes
sociaux en fait pour communiquer avec
nous et qu'on besoin de tout réapprendre
et avant d'avoir les connaissances d'un
métier les connaissances d'un d'une
relation sociale
je faisais du vélo mais j'avais pas
vraiment de connaissances mon mari
connaît très bien mais j'ai du mal à
toucher le vélo avec lui et je voulais
apprendre par moi-même en fait on est
chacun sur un pied avec un vélo on se
débrouille et canton
on peut plus et qu'on sait plus faire on
appelle à l'aide au niveau de la force
physique des fois je me dis mais je n'ai
jamais arrivé à défaire ses crew et puis
finalement
en prenant confiance aussi parce que on
arrive à faire plein de choses
ouais moi j'avais presque envie de
monter ma boîte donc je suis
j'ai réfléchi à ça en fait en parallèle
c'est la première fois que je vais au
travail et que c'est cool
vraiment je prends plaisir à venir et
[Musique]
on leur demande de faire preuve d'audace
c'est-à-dire de miser à nouveau sur eux
et à dire qu'il ya des personnes que
j'ai pu connaître à qui j'ai confié au
début un tournevis et ils ont fait des
étincelles
aujourd'hui je leur confie les équipes
leur confie des bâtiments gens qu'on
fait des véhicules et continue à évoluer
et continuer plus loin et puis surtout à
transmettre à leur tour
donc on a une partie qui ici qu'est tout
ce qui est des dons de vélo avec emmaüs
on a eu notre parti on a créé six postes
pour les services lire pour une
réparation que ce soit une petite une
grande ou moyenne
tout se passe par ici on a vraiment vu
des personnes se redresser reprendre un
sourire recommencer à on va dire as
essayé et ça c'est vraiment à ce
extraordinaire au quotidien de pouvoir
être témoin toutes ces émotions
[Musique]
l'on démonte absolument tous les cadres
on les met à nu on free l'inox le métal
l'aluminium
on récupère toutes les pièces qui
peuvent être de nouveau utilisées et on
essaie d'être un maximum responsables
quant à notre production de déchets
et du coude ou futurs on est vraiment
tous responsables aujourd'hui quand on
achète un vélo faut savoir d'où est ce
qu'il vient à quoi il sert à l'atelier
de l'audace au moins on a une espèce de
contrat de confiance
on sait que le vélo il a été récupéré
par des personnes qui ont besoin d'un
emploi aujourd'hui en france c'est 27
mille tonnes de déchets cycle il ya
vraiment une nécessité d'arrêter de
consommer du neuf et de revenir sur ce
qu'on a des là surtout que ce qu'on
produisait dans les années 80 par
exemple c'est de la super bonne qualité
[Musique]